[Music]
thank you
oh the beautiful snowfall to lead us
into the show today welcome back to the
break room Our Daily Show that keeps you
updated on all the nerdy fandom news you
need to know coming up on the show today
Kang's Jonathan major had an interesting
interview we got some D we got some into
the spider-verse details as we wait for
the trailer coming tomorrow can't wait
Joker 2's New Image yeah the script says
images but it's image singular hey folks
are you down with OPP yeah wait wait
don't scared of that clean come on
you down with OPP and Heimer yeah you
know me and Heimer that's right that's
right good job you know me and bombs hey
bumps I'm Brandon but who cares across
the table today we got Erica Wilson
good to see y'all it's been too long uh
next to Eric we got Jessica Clement Eric
said that we look like siblings a day
and I'm gonna run with it forever
siblings are they siblings do they know
yes and next to me the real OG Tommy B
hi everyone great to be here as we
finish out our year and we begin to look
forward to 2023. some goals that I've
said for myself personally
fit on the ride
Thomas Thomas
help help me ag-1
oh my goodness uh if you were here last
Friday we had a great holiday party I'm
still drunk it was tons of fun thank you
for all the uh sweet toast you folks set
in all the super chats it was so much
fun we don't have a Redemption today but
if you want to send it any super chats
we'll get to your questions we'll read
them on the air we'll feel we're feeling
Punchy this is our last week of shows
for the year before we take a
well-deserved break uh so we're gonna be
looking ahead for 2023 this week and all
the exciting content that's coming down
the pipeline yeah it's a huge uh to the
Future speaking of the future let's talk
about the man of the Future King himself
oh the the big bad the big band and all
the in every Marvel film that's going to
come out uh for the next two years maybe
uh because Peyton Reed he did an
interview where he mentioned channeling
his love for the Fantastic Four into the
Ant-Man movies Peyton Reed of course
directing Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania kicking off phase five
featuring King as a villain uh he had
this to say about the comparison between
the Ant-Man movies and the Fantastic
Four he said quote they're both stories
about families of superheroes uh and he
also mentioned in an interview that he
has seen the initial artwork for the
Fantastic Four film okay yeah it's like
storyboards you know yeah show it yeah
dioramas like Elementary School all
right guys we hired some board artists
bring in your Fantastic Four Diaries you
can clearly see whose mom did that yeah
I was up on a paper mache a Susan storm
the Human Torch figurine is on fire yeah
right they light up
uh well we all know that Marvel's like
really secretive about this kind of
stuff do you do you folks think that
Peyton has seen the art because he's
somehow involved like his Kang is
involved in Fantastic Four that would
make sense like oh I'm so sorry you were
gonna make the same point I understand I
think I'm going to make things no no you
say first because I should not be
watching 2022 is the year of the lady
finish up
I think uh I've been right in this wave
that'd be really funny
all these ladies be yelling at me that'd
be interesting I don't think this is
gonna happen but just like Rogue
theory-ish if you will if a variant of
Kang was Doctor Doom and I love the idea
of that just making him still a
completely brilliant scientist it's just
this one's Doctor Doom so yeah it would
make sense for it to come into terms and
Fantastic Four I love that idea only
because in the original Secret Wars
comic Doom meets Kang and he's like
surely I'm a king and Kang is like
absolutely not we're not related
and in the comics uh is it Nathaniel
Richards Future Super Future uh read
Richard yeah yeah
so that could tie into the face yeah we
were talking about that right like there
must be you know every movie that's
coming out in Phase five and phase six
we have to wonder if there's like Kang
involvement there how deep does the king
go some cane juice
is your king
I really need to know cause we're living
in a world so small
and many is here and we know
where will he show will he cheat with
Janet
I'm just speculating I actually had a
completely different point on this
what's your completely different point I
think he had to see the art because uh
the post-credit team in Quantum media is
going to be a Fantastic Four teaser so
he had to make sure that he was putting
in although they usually have the
director from the movie that the
post-credit scene is implying director
that I think maybe Peyton Reed had to
have some sort of either lay some Easter
eggs or groundwork in the actual film
proper or in the post-credit or
mid-credits scene now I'm not a
provocateur on the internet okay I don't
see things I don't I don't you know I
don't report for explosive nerdgasm and
have weird takes on like you know insult
takes on things but are we worried about
getting a Kang over
um it feels like Pang is in at like the
spec like we are speculating Kang is
right every property now Thanos very
very famously
spread in for a lot of things sure we're
like Kang will be the villain in all of
these things does Jonathan Majors want
to commit the next like seven years of
his life to be in gang maybe it's fun I
would for the money but I'm you know a
bit of a prosecutor can you put up face
six really quick
um I think okay so Fantastic Four
allegedly comes before Avengers game
yeah so the Fantastic Four would have
the end credit that leads us to the Kang
Dynasty
plenty of other projects yes yeah so it
but it only goes up until like that and
I feel like after uh wait bring it back
up one more time so sorry I feel like
after Secret Wars It's kind of messy
unless there's two parts to Secret Wars
because Secret Wars is a lot involved
for sure but I could see that being
King's finishing yeah and that's 2024 I
think was the timeline 26. 2024 he
started in 2020 with uh filming Loki
that's true so I think that duration is
a good amount of duration
I mean I think it's very possible that
Peyton Reed was maybe in the pool of
potential directors for Fantastic Four
and that's how he saw these like
storyboards because we know that Marvel
puts together these animatics of like
yeah you can make a movie but this fight
scene has to happen so uh get to this at
some point because when I say no King
over okay
maybe run upon the chat do you guys
think we'll see Kang in uh Fantastic
Four we've recained our confidence well
Penn Reed also mentioned that the tone
of this Ant Man movie is the same as the
first two until the movie takes a quote
Dark Turn what a dark featuring Me Maybe
featuring her we never know why which I
I do I do get that Essence from the
trailer right the beginning of the
trailer looks like yeah it looks like
the other animated watch movie is very
silly kind of light-hearted and then the
song shifts from right actual rendition
of uh Goodbye Yellow Brick Road to a
like dark dark epic yeah
Peyton also said that the situation is
very personal to them especially Janet
Van Dyne now we've heard from some of
our own sources that this movie will
feature her very heavily and she'll be
more of a co-leader in this film which I
think it's smart we know so little about
her you can really use her uh she'll
freaking fight yeah and she had 30 years
down in the quantum realm to F around
and find out yeah uh let me find out
also like if by how long are you in the
quantum realm before you're like I can
hook up with someone else now right my
husband's not coming right Jessica and I
talked about we have a realm agreement
if we go to different Realms we're
allowed to hook up with other people you
said Margot Robbie I said Jonathan
Majors if they're in the quantum realm
oh wait no my world is not my number one
listen I can do better than me
I'm just kidding Margo if you're
watching come on the break room
I'll love you forever hey we your
husband doesn't care about you all the
folks uh watch you know this because
they watch everything we do on the
channel thank you so much uh but we had
a really cute Rogue Theory this weekend
about the possibility that Janet has kid
a kid or kids in the quantum realm uh is
this what she's hiding or do you think
it's something more directly related to
Kang but she may be hooking up maybe she
was like the queen to Kang's king or
vice that would be she's the king he's
the queen uh and then she's a kid yeah
well that's the thing the thing is like
that I I want to believe that there is a
child in there but just for storytelling
purposes wouldn't that make her like
kind of an unlikable character to like
not even try to get back into the
quantum realm to get her child unless
her child did age quicker because we
don't know how time works in the quantum
realm and it is all right remember her
child's an [ __ ] she's like don't turn
on that radio I don't want to talk to my
kids very famously in that adorable
episode of Rogue 3 that aired over the
weekend on our Channel and go back and
watch it I took a little bit of heat for
suggesting maybe the child was like Hey
Mama I don't want to go back I like this
yeah I like the only World they've ever
known this is where I'm happy just
because you want to get back to some guy
that you know is up there making pen
particles I don't know that world yeah
or I had also suggested perhaps she was
already pregnant she was sucked into the
quantum realm oh and that child who is
hanked him son or hey because he never
got to meet him and he had to grow up in
the quantum realm and now he's now he's
an adult Bill Murray oh my age faster
yeah whatever the quantum realm but
that's a good theory I mean every MCU
movie that's come out lately has had
like a hey there's a kid now hey there's
a kid now so like yeah that is true
though coming on the on the heels of
wukanda forever if the reveal is also
like meet your other son meet another
son meet another someone else's daughter
I mean like here's another direct
lineage that my to be hats on hats on I
mean phase four was a lot about family
and a lot about children and the kids
and like what what these Heroes need for
the Next Generation which is a very
unique thing that the movies are able to
do that the comics do less well bad
sentence structure because the comics
they're almost ageless for a long time
like they slowly age in the comics and
slowly have children but in these movies
you know in between movies these actors
and they age a few years and it's like
they only have a limited amount of time
yeah before they're they're phased out
of these movies so it makes sense that
like we had so many kids introduced yes
and the actors in the real world had
kids and like put my kid in the movie
because we don't have enough money do
you think they're gonna do more time
jumps and this is a big question for
another day but do you think like to get
Toussaint a little older they're gonna
like do another no because it takes them
so long to make these I mean they were
talking about Young Avengers it's like
five right but you we've been talking
about younger adventures with the
children that are already there they're
all going to be they have to do not have
a Young Avengers movie on the Slate all
of these people will be old enough to
just be the Avengers like if they want
Young Avengers they gotta start with
babies babies
official ones is Thor's and black right
yeah Thor by Panther I mean Tommy and
Wiccan are still little babies
they're still young enough but like
people talk about hailee Steinfeld being
a young Avenger she's an event she's old
enough to just be an Avenger yeah it's
like 40. yeah yeah she's at least 50
years old uh she got some good aim with
the large arrows why do you think we're
trying to say you up with everyone why
are all these girls so thirsty for me
Steinfeld keep it in your pants keep it
in your pants well Tommy you mentioned a
like a king overdose right well Jonathan
Majors he he's he said that the only
reason he's well not the only reason but
one of the reasons he said yes to
playing King in the first place when
they brought him in it's he who remains
in Loki is because that he would be
allowed to play multiple variants in
these characters which is so great uh He
also mentioned that he does not know if
the Kang in quantumania will be the same
Kang and Kang Dynasty now he could he's
pulling a Marvel right he's like I don't
know I don't know but I love that I like
to think that Kevin has uh in a way that
in the same way that uh she who must not
be named you know told uh rigmund that
like this is how Snape's character goes
in the Harry Potter franchise so you
know so you can put these little acting
tropes in throughout the movie franchise
I would imagine that Jonathan Majors
knows something about like which king
goes where and how to play these
different Kings because he's going to
have a different style of acting for all
these different Kings he needs to know
which ones need to line up I think he
does know more than he's he's letting
out in all of his interviews he's very
he talks the least I think Paul red
talks a lot uh uh
um
Evangeline Lilly she she talks a lot
he's Jonathan major is always very quiet
I think he's very afraid of saying too
yeah yeah he wants to get a few of these
movies under his belt right right he's
got to get a feeling he's not trying to
be a Tom Holland right out of the gate
right oh
um you know and we've talked about this
about a lot around the office especially
when it relates to Kang uh how they make
us care about characters that could die
and come back without consequence right
or does that make a villain scarier if
if that's not possible Right like we're
in this weird Multiverse situation we're
like yeah they could kill off a
character but then just bring them back
and now they've traveled through time
and they haven't really pulled that
trigger yet of like killing someone and
well they did with Gamora I take that
back they did it with Gabor they killed
her and then brought her back she's
different but it's Gamora right and when
at the end of end game they're not
killing the Thanos that did the snap
right they're killing of that Thanos
from another timeline yeah because they
would have killed Thanos Thanos he tried
to do it yeah you know
did make it like satisfy almost as
satisfying as it would have been if it
had been that Thanos that died I also
think the speech from these uh Loki
season finale that he who remains gives
about how there are like kill me if you
want but there are versions of me that
are so much scared that gives inherently
that character the power to like yeah
you kill one king off but it's like that
means we're probably meeting a worse one
every time yeah so like with that it is
you can see that character die and come
back as a variant just because you know
it's like sequels they're gonna get
bigger and better and you can't do you
can't make a remake as a sequel you have
to make it more explosive you have to
make the characters bigger the action
bigger so the Kang has to be more evil
that's all that's what I mean I can't
wait to see the Sister Act 2 back in the
habitat yeah
oh man but then I'm so happy today
but and also it in low-key I love that
in setting up the time variants and
Kang's power and just like they
basically made the Infinity Stones
futile like they were in the desk drawer
of an employee at the TVA so like this
new phase moving out of the infinity
phase and going to the Multiverse and
stuff beyond that is is going to
completely blow the infinity Saga and
stones out of the water we thought the
Infinity Stones were super powerful and
it was just big and scary Kang's about
to irrevocably change the MCU forever
yeah and I've pitched this theory on
Rogue there I think the Kang in
quantumania is the dumbest Kang he's
stuck in the quantum realm he can't get
out because he's too stupid to figure
out again and they'll kill him and then
that's your dumbest one yeah yeah and
he's just like a little ant in a
bathroom
and that's why she's like I can't be
seen so Jana van dime is also a king I
love this guy I think he's just got King
damage uh I love this chat from Abdul
Mohammed uh Kang causes fantastic for
his accident and gives him hours I like
that especially if maybe the way that we
have Kang in these phase five is Phase
five right phase five phase five uh
movies and TV shows is if he's just as
puppet master that is making all these
things happen and sometimes let me know
oh those of us that are puppeteers it's
been my passion for a long time publics
don't always move the way you want
sometimes they move to it they got a
life of their own sometimes they become
little boys that do their own songs and
go off to an island and become donkeys
oh but only the boys Pinocchio right
reference
little girls are perfect and they can
never do anything that's the only reason
why I love that movie I was like oh I'm
never going to that Island no you would
be that person at that Island
don't care you'd be like I want to be
with Maestro show me that show me that
whale
even if donkey ears boy do they play
craps on this island that was well
sometimes
[Music]
another thing we could talk about
Jessica Cardinals running line tonight
let's go I just gambled with all of our
hearts that's true another thing we
gotta talk about is this big into the
spider across the spider-verse trailer
that we know is coming tomorrow we know
it's coming at 9 A.M Pacific we're gonna
we're gonna do our reaction as soon as
it drops on the channel uh uh Jessica's
gonna do a breakdown Eric's gonna do a
different breakdown if he's gonna do a
different breakdown
yeah left out all these breakdowns
guess what the gang's getting back
together yeah and then as we were like
let's do this trailer breakdown Tommy
was like the band's back together hey
finally but yes you son of a [ __ ]
uh in the UK and it's like 8 P.M like 5
p.m in uh you can't believe and then
noon on the east coast and then who
cares about the rest of the time and
yeah uh yes and there's been a lot of
stuff that's already been revealed maybe
like pre-trailery
um from film magazine and we're gonna go
through it right now because there's a
lot of stuff that's setting up that is
very fun and I'm more than excited
number one biggest thing spot the
villain who we know that has different
portals within their body that when you
jump through you punch through it takes
you to a different dimension uh will be
the villain of the next two movies so I
think that includes this one in part two
of into the across the spider verse
because it's a two-parter so this guy
will be actually a big bat and though
he's really silly and I've talked about
it on the break room before how he was
just a scientist that went into a tunnel
that wasn't fixed yet and then was like
oh I'm just gonna go in there and then
he got changed into a Dalmatian
um but yeah he will be the villain
number two they said the unique dilemma
of being Gwen Stacy she's a vigilante
seen as responsible for the death of her
world's Peter Parker as we know from the
first one to make matters worse the cop
in charge of tracking her down as her
father
thank you guys for the yes and yeah how
do we feel about that story so far I
like it I mean I'm excited to see more
about Gwen station yes you know yeah we
got a lot of Spider-Man I want more Gwen
States well the thing is I'm genuinely
interested in all of the Spider-Man from
the first movie like maybe not Jake
Johnson's because we got a little bit of
backstory on him but like Noir Spiderman
I want to learn more about Spider-Man
spider uh robot yeah Japanese 20.99 or
whatever or 29 good something it's a
number isn't it I thought I thought that
was the other Spider-Man oh man I just
always referred her as the Spiderman
that's uh robot is has a spider inside
that her dad created
um question question uh did they did I
probably missed this who's doing the
voice of spot uh Jason Schwartzman Jason
Schwartzman he's great he's got a great
voice um wasn't he in the first
Spiderman no way home oh no
maybe I'm thinking of someone else okay
either way
um I think Wednesday is Jake and Jill
and Hallman that's the one thank you for
prisoners yes
um so the Gwen Stacy story already
follows the edge of spider-verse uh
issues from 2014 where Gwen Stacy uh
everyone assumed okay so just like this
is a comic book yeah it's a comic book
in 2014 edge of spider versus the second
issue is Gwen Stacy first issues uh Noir
Spider-Man where Gwen Stacy reveals to
her dad that she is spider one the
spider Gwen and the entire series or the
entire issue
on site not my daughter
um it's an actually really good story
because she it follows actually our
Miles Morales do you know how miles uh
fat was was found by his dad on his
uncle's body and then zoomed away and
his dad was like it was the Spider-Man
the same thing happened with when Stacey
and her dad when they saw Peter Parker
dad like it was spider Gwen so they're
but unlike uh miles dad who eventually
saw him save the day and was like the
Spiderman's not a bad guy spider Gwen's
dad was like No And so they always yeah
it's on site and they kept trying to
jump her bad guys and good guys that was
also a universe where
um Daredevil was a bad guy Matt Murdoch
was an actual villain and it's really
good it's very fun and it's really deep
because it involves her family just
being like I'm Spider-Man but I'm here
to help just as much as you are so
that's maybe the storyline we can
probably see uh it also goes on to say
after uniting with Gwen Stacy Brooklyn's
full-time friendly neighborhood
Spider-Man is catapulted across the
Multiverse where he encounters a team of
spider people charged with protecting
his very existence but when the heroes
Clash on uh how to handle a new threat
I'm assuming spot miles finds himself
pitted against the other spiders and
must redefine what it means to be a hero
so he can save the people he loves most
interestingly he's got to conquer
bureaucracy I love that for him sound
like our Spider-Man in the last movie
where he had to work with the other
Spider-Man and it was really hard
because they're normally working on
right but there he's getting them home
right and he's on his home turf and this
he's traveling through and it sounds
like to me it's going to be one of those
situations where like well we gotta
destroy some of these universes to
protect ours and he's gonna be like no
one dies today you know I'm Not Gonna
Save everybody but some of it you know
it's like that classic thing with the
Illuminati in the comics right where
they're like we got to destroy these
other worlds to save ours and it's like
who gets to make that decision yeah you
know there's people that are wrote
Illuminati yeah yeah psych reverse yeah
now what if spots just like my body is
gonna open up a giant multiversal you
like black hole to where everyone's
gonna die and he's like kind of like
he's the bad guy but he's a bad guy
because he knows that he like he he
knows bad things are going to happen so
he has to do like he has to do bad
things and Destroy close the universes
up so that he doesn't destroy all the
universes and miles is like there's got
to be a way it's the trolley problem
right do I kill off one Universe to save
90 or do I let 90 universes die and do
nothing you know they uh they finish the
the film magazine interview with the
spot and miles are connected in
surprising ways and I like that well
like how I said the Gwen Stacy story
mimicking literally Miles Morales story
what if spot is like in a different
universe is his dad
he just goes by his last name Jefferson
oh but what if he what if that was him
or something like that I feel like spot
is just jumping just dimensions and
going off and setting off everything in
the worst way I'm not crazy though that
in the comics his name is Jefferson
Davis which is also the name of the
president of the Confederacy I just want
to try and say something real left up
here I'm not 100 sure can someone can
someone pay 50 cents
so it's like the spider verse so it
looks like it's like the story is really
connecting with spent uh Spider Gwen but
it's also just like miles fighting a
bunch of different Spider-Man but also
working alongside a bunch of different
Spider-Man does that seem like it's
gonna end up good
I hope uh I mean it doesn't if we know
there's like another movie after this
and an involved spot this feels like the
uh The Empire Strikes Back right we're
gonna end on a real down yeah yeah it's
good like things are a mess spider-ham's
gonna be honest universe is a pineapple
and cherries
are we gonna see the other
I hope so and I hope we see other
villains and not just spot I would love
to see I thought there's more villains I
thought there was some villain casting
maybe not but are we definitely going to
see Oscar Isaac's character right yeah
yeah we see him Miguel O'Hara We're
Gonna See Spot we're gonna see spider
Gwen we're gonna see hobby which is uh
Daniel kalua's character oh yeah Jessica
Drew played by Issa Rae yes
um and maybe Mrs Webb or Madam Webb
maybe I maybe yeah maybe a madame web I
pitched in a theory video that we'll see
Doc Ock live again and Miguel O'Hara's
universe so the female doc [ __ ] yeah oh
she survived I think well I think I
think yeah l-i-b-e like she lives
I read that that way and maybe Brandon
and I will both play variants of rhino
with this classic I love that for you
guys
also this just said Tommy is Right Tommy
is right they named him Jefferson Davis
because Tommy was right about that being
the president of the Confederacy yes
so you know I mean my passion's always
been the Confederacy so let's move on
quickly yeah well we are super hyped
we're across the spider verse I mean and
it's downfall
into the spider-verse was like my
favorite film of that year I will never
forget the first time I saw it and then
the three other times I watched it in
theaters and I have one on 4K Blu-ray it
is incredible it is so good physical
media oh I got it on physical media
folks because you know why when you're
streaming a 4K video on the internet
it's not coming in at 4K they're still
compression this sounds terrible buy the
physical media don't let these companies
tell you you own a product and it lives
on a cloud somewhere someday the dead
will rise from their graves and chew
through our electronic infrastructure
and you're going to want a way to watch
this our electronic infrastructure
aren't they chew through your DVD player
I'm gonna say that one wire I'm gonna
have a car battery I'm gonna pedal a
bike
listen to me you can never truly own a
cloud that's true you could never own a
God knows I've tried I don't care how
many years you spend in meteorology
school you can own a cloud you can own a
4K DVD player you can own a PlayStation
5. well if anyone it's actually very
hard to understand I got one in my house
I don't know who it is Peter Jackson's
KK King Kong spring for the steelbook
spring for the steel book so they can't
crush it when the zombies come together
here's the DVDs as coasters if you can't
bring yourself to watch them but guys
don't let the dead take our electricity
I will never listen to YouTube in the
zombie show if you're like get the DVD
uh another couple quick headlines for
today
headlines graphic
I hear clicking there it is yeah sorry I
sprung that on you Johnny so much you
guys I stayed up all night watching
highlights of the Buffalo Bills swapping
of the New Jersey jets I thought you
were just bored of us boy oh boy uh our
first headline Joker has a new image
let's check out that awful image there
it is oh fun
yeah what a Whimsical looking oh see
look at look at the top right corner top
right corner photo that's definitely
another inmate dude even the top left
corner top left corner that's a safety
razor God knows I've been familiar I
mean we know this is a musical are they
doing Sweeney Todd is that the musical
they're gonna try don't make that face
but Jessica did point this out and I
didn't even notice this because I was so
disgusted by that concave chest uh he's
got another prisoner shaving his face so
he's he's the king of the inmates yeah I
think he's going into prison after all
of those people rallied in the streets
destroyed for him killed Batman's
parents for him yeah and I think they're
now in prison he's just gonna be the
number one he's the number one
my face because I'm the Joker then we'll
play some prison poker we're gonna have
fun making a rogue Gallery
cause Life's a joke when you go to jail
with me or the Joker I am on the job
I love it I love I like the idea that
you're in prison with the joker who's
making you dance
some people Bane some people just
traffic crack cocaine but they're all in
jail with the Joker that's me that's odd
that's oil a little a little bit of
Peter Pan for you folks out there uh we
also got some new images from
Oppenheimer yeah you know me the reality
oh look look at Iron Man yeah oh yeah
Robert Downey Jr's in this film uh Celia
Murphy the scarecrows in this film uh
yeah this is Nolan's next big joint
coming out this summer uh they've been
they got uh several movie theaters
across the country have large countdown
clocks getting ready for this you know
Nola was pissed about tenant no one went
to the movies to go see it because they
didn't want to die of covid what's a big
movie this time he wants a big movie
this time I think he's gonna get it we
were talking about this in the office it
sounds like they made a huge explosion
like they wanted to replicate a nuclear
explosion they obviously didn't set off
a nuke I hope I'm sure Nolan asked if it
could be done uh but it sounds like
they've done a big practical explosion
explosion or multiple practical
explosions for this film wow very
excited for whatever you think of
Nolan's films I mean he's at least out
there trying some stuff making weird
stuff doing a lot of practical effects
in his movies at least he's not shooting
a car into the moon he's not shooting a
car to the Moon Murphy playing Scarecrow
in this or uh yes he is reprising his
roller skates yeah he's capturing the
bomb in a case yeah
he's just around the country blowing
smoke in their face being like
Harrison splitting the atom and all the
uh effects it's had afterwards but we're
all very excited about this film I don't
know if you Folks at home we're excited
about are you are you excited for an
Oppenheimer film are you excited for
Nolan's next picture everyone's excited
for an open Island I I think I'm more
Jazz than I was yesterday I'm very I'm
like ooh good cast yeah great very
historical moment let's watch it let's
see yeah I'll be honest I think that
movie's gonna be
Devon
lovely beautiful
um someone's super chat right now and
Tommy will have to take a shot of the
hot sauce that we keep in the fridge
folks holidays are right around the
corner and a great place to find
yourself something a little special
special for that lady or a man in your
life it's right here at
newrockstarsmerch.com there's tons of
awesome new rockstars merch to check out
and if you're worried about knowing
someone's sizes or their size agnostic
merch options for you to choose from
including hats mugs stickers and enamel
pins I love those enamels yeah they do
have this like they got a lot of
different sticker sets on this site but
they also sell like you you might
recognize these from uh yeah from some
of our uh uh trailer thumbs or different
thumbs on there turn your family photos
does she know yeah yeah you can you can
go in and like what's up yeah yeah
what's what's top a little Easter eggs
it's the teeth a little easier they show
white on your own family photos really
Jazz up your holidays they find the same
shade of denim in five five shirts it's
hard it's difficult denim is a it's a
natural occurring fabric you're a better
you're a bit of a denim guy I'm a bit of
a denim head all right guys support the
channel for crying out loud check out
all the awesome merch options over at
New rockstarsmerch.com and dress like
the pros do it's time for mandatory
anymore
clearing gear and so we play the graphic
again
oh the segment is on both the naughty
and nice list so we play it thriceless
here again
yes the segment that uh has uh so much
legend that we play the Thirsty that's
being graphic don't play it I don't like
that graphic oh thank God
for two more Graphics please
all right fine we won't play that
graphic again hit the comment change the
spider Gwen
there it is there it is thick thick yum
oh she might be a teenager in that movie
I don't know all right
she's still in high school well I'm
gonna pretend that she's uh maybe a
couple of years age and she's uh like in
her 30s they are truly in the Golden Era
of gritty holiday movies this week alone
you could Feast your eyes on a violent
night with David Harbor playing Santa
Claus breaking the laws of Man by Taking
Lives uh you can watch your mean one a a
horror movie instead in the Grinch verse
I believe unauthorized but done with
loving care and I think open and over
100 theaters this week so that is how is
it unauthorized and in a hundred
theaters well I think they can I don't I
don't know
they've never refer to him as the Grinch
he's just a green a greenhouse
what I've read from the synopsis uh it's
the the classic Grinch story but instead
of stealing Christmas he also murdered
Cindy Lou whose parents in front of her
so it sets a Revenge tail for it and
finally Christmas Bloody Christmas
starring The Amazing ape Ben Ruby a dear
sweet man uh you can actually rent that
on demand he plays a very evil Santa
Claus I highly recommend renting that
Abe is a fantastic actor you know from
ER and many any many many other projects
He did not pay me to say any of this but
he is a great guy so anyway I know we
can do better than that right though so
I want you guys to all pitch me your
best gritty Christmas movies what do you
got
you got one
um yeah yeah so I think okay am I
pitching this and by the way send us in
the chats to your best Christmas movies
yeah if you got some chats my vision is
a Tommy or t Michael back T Michael's
not here he's in jail it's just me I'm a
jail company now see Michael always goes
to jail for the holidays yeah he always
goes to prison because he loves their
soups around the holidays I guess three
Hots in a cot yeah that's right ooh you
got soups for all three I love this all
right so what's your movie okay hear me
out okay hear me out close your eyes
imagine this right so you you guys are
all fans of elves on the elf on a shelf
yeah of course I I wouldn't call myself
a fan but I'm aware of the situation yes
I think there's a story there where a
young girl has an elf on the shelf and
she loves it she adores it right but uh
every time she wakes up the elf in the
Shelf is in her bedroom playing with her
dolls right but it's it's like it's like
Andy's home like they're not moving
they're standing right and the dolls are
always in weird positions like they're
one's like dead clearly it has like a
knife through like a little fake knife
through its arm or something like that
and then when she wakes up every morning
after seeing it someone in her life is
dead that way
like a voodoo situation and she can't
touch the elf and okay she's afraid
don't touch the Elf on the Shelf but
every night the Elf on the Shelf goes
into her Barbie room and then plays with
whatever dolls and puts it in a position
where it's like what's going on and then
one of her neighbors every night dies
that way and her parents are like you
you need to stop having these nightmares
go to sleep and it's like no no
wake up in my dreams bone chilling
What's the title of this movie
um I think uh
elf in the doll house I would say uh it
should be called
uh kill the Elf or kill myself get the
elf out of here oh that's a good one all
right Eric what do you got for us all
right
I have a holiday read imagining of Home
Alone okay so in this gritty retelling
this is the origin story of the sticky
and also the wet Bandits Marvin Harry so
this is their origin story they didn't
start off Robin houses they started off
murdering people
going on a murderous freeze around the
holidays cold-blooded murders
cold-blooded murderers no Vengeance no
mercy killings no euthanasias oh my God
just straight up
just straight up holiday killings kill
me
I'll kill your spry grandchildren
instead that's that's their job are you
scared math kill that old lady but then
into the film they start to get
murderous inclinations towards each
other so that was a game of cat and a
mouse between each other and we we play
a whole movie out around the holidays
and Kwanzaa to see if they kill each
other or not and the film is called home
alone has the bones whoa
I like that Guess who's coming to sinner
um
Brandon what do you got okay I want to
see a gritty reboot of Frosty the
Snowman oh I know we had that Jack Frost
movie which was more just like
psychologically unsettling uh the fact
that their father's Spirit was trapped
in there yeah he's still trying to Bone
them up yeah yeah yeah that was a little
bit crazy snowman yeah horny for your
mom still even he's like I can put this
carrot wherever I want it's also one
that puts the soup and then he melts
away no that was a commercial
soup
kid tell your mom to run the air
conditioner
and then I'm coming inside tonight
in this in this gritty room of Frosty
the Snowman the magical hat it doesn't
blow onto a snowman it blows into a
cocaine house uh where they're packaging
coconuts
yes the shot at my wife the Hat Man the
Hat lands on a pile of cocaine and the
cocaine comes to life oh my God and it
goes goes to the houses of cocaine
people are buying and selling cocaine
and it sucks all the cocaine out of
their body absorbing it all and if any
of the children of these people it takes
them with them uh and it travels the
streets sucking the cocaine out of out
of different drug users and coming
becoming stronger and stronger and
larger and larger until the town is just
full of more and more confidence yeah
more and more confidence he's up all
night looking at porn on the Internet
why don't we make our own movies
to go into business for ourselves all we
need is ten thousand dollars ten
thousand dollars should be enough and we
can make our own movies and the only way
to kill him is all the children have to
snort them until he's gone now the
children are hopped up uh and they go
crazy
why can't they go into business for
ourselves
if they're doing the Matilda dance on
reboot
and it's called Uh Cokey the Snowman
what oh Frosty The Blue Man from John
that could be confused with the porno
John yeah that's true yeah that's called
glossy the blow man
what's yours crazy the blue all right
mine is uh from the old Rankin bass
Rudolph the Red-Nosed Reindeer cartoon
I've got two it's a horror Anthology
film the first film opens in a dentist
chair uh where an elderly man with
pointy ears uh sits down
my teeth have been killing me
oh you're the only dentist open on
Christmas what's your name Herbie sir
and I think it's time we extracted the
pain from you hey Curry wants to be a
dentist and then it's Herbie killing his
patients where all else the second oh
okay okay it's like a little Tales from
the Crypt thing yeah I like that then
the second thing is Yukon Cornelius the
famous Ginger Explorer from Yukon
Cornelius
[Music]
how do you measure
just by the joy that it brings here on
he's been so singing today he's been
he's in the holiday spirit I'm still
high from the ambient I'm still drunk
from the holiday party anyway all right
so listen to me so here's what here's
how it's going uh you got Cornelius has
uh got a tip on some gold so he gets a
crew of Santa's best elves and Reindeer
and the big man himself even joins and
they go to get their Fortune so they can
finally quit giving these spoiled brats
presents on Christmas but they're good
brats
not all of them
some of them belong on the Island of
Misfit Toys so anyway they're gonna go
and they go and they Pine for they mine
for the gold and a snowstorm hits and
they get snowed in and the only way to
survive is to eat each other oh all the
reindeer turned into jerky Santa turned
into jerky oh the Abominable Snowman
turned into jerky only Yukon survives as
he comes back into the North Pole
Santa's workshop with blood in his mouth
bags of gold him and Mrs Claus run off
together part three of the Anthology
series
The Island of Misfit Toys oh okay
suddenly from Beneath The Island of
Misfit Toys are rumbling there's a
precious four unobtainium in the island
Hugh the soldiers from Avatar they come
in here oh yeah strip it of all of its
unobkadium this whole trilogy is called
Rudolph the red the dead nose slaying
deer
so many studios would have to cross over
to make this film yeah yeah it's the
biggest they would it's the biggest
thing by the way I was in Cokey the
Snowman and that's where I got the idea
for all of this we're Frosty the blow
man we haven't decided on a title
or facial the the
okay
I'm the suck man baby how dare you how
dare you you knew me when you met me
you'd have to share me baby uh Jamie
Riley standing on a Super Chat saying
Deadpool 2 is my favorite Christmas
movie then kick ass oh is there
Christmas in Kick-Ass I don't remember
no I think yeah it doesn't he die around
Christmas it sounds like a big deal is
that the second one the first one he
dies yeah oh Big Daddy yeah because he
gives her the knife for Christmas The
Butterfly oh okay that all makes sense
that all makes a lot of sense my
favorite Christmas movie is Mean Girls
okay oh you guys don't agree oh it does
that it has a part that takes place
during Christmas that makes a Canon yes
yeah my favorite my favorite Christmas
movie is The Passion of the Christ
that's an Easter movie yeah yeah any
movie with Christ is a Christmas movie
oh okay it does have Christ in the title
it's true uh we did ask the chat which
2023 movies they're most excited for 38
said Mario movie
32 said Dune part two which must be Zach
logging into all his accounts and voting
for Tuesday I'm very excited for June
part two uh 90 often I wear 10 fast 10
maybe they're just keeping it ten fasted
fast 10 your seat belts is what they
should have named the movie and I'm
really irritated they have not I think
it saves a lot every movie I think
they're when the trailer drops are gonna
say best 10-year seat belts they better
oh they better oh that's good
specifically you yeah they better thank
me I want a personal thank you from Vin
Diesel Rudolph the dead nose Plain
Dealer oh my gosh
so we also asked the chat who's dark
Holly movie they want to watch the most
Jessica ran away with it with hope in
the dollhouse Tommy I think you got
screwed because your pitch took so long
yeah
only 88 people voted well what is this
the Georgia runoff oh my gosh Brandon's
was a good one I like the idea of uh
just the Hat just
they gotta get the
kids
look at the guy on the couch just keep s
on like this
That's a classic holiday movie
he only sleeps one hour a week but when
he does he's screaming send it into SNL
folks well thanks for tuning in today be
sure to like And subscribe the show if
you haven't already we only got four
more episodes at the break room this
year before we're after the holidays uh
uh we got Whitney's Rick and Morty
season finale breakdown will be coming
out on the channel on Wednesday
and like we said tomorrow mtjs and boss
are gonna have their trailer reactions
to Across the spider verse uh and Anna's
got a breakdown for the Mario movie
footage that will be up on the channel
tomorrow check out all that awesome
stuff check it out
today
thanks for tuning in we'll be back all
your Breakers and roomies and trash bags
out there trash bag did send in a Super
Chat asking if they could get a shish
Charming could they get a she's oh I
don't know I'm kind of retiring
all right
it's true